mais toi là tu viens d'où mais comme
vraiment de où c'est quoi au juste
chinois est adopté et ton père et ta
mère qui étonnera c'est vraiment un beau
mélange texte que j'avais écrit qu
s'appelait le jour où j'ai réalisé que
j'étais asiatique dans ce texte lu mon
but c'était de raconter le moment en
fait la première fois où je me suis fait
poser la question du bien tout donc
c'est une question qu'on se fait
constamment posée en tant que personne
de genomics donc j'avais envie de
confronter cette question le puits dit
répond une fois pour toutes dans un
texte puis j'ai abordé les thématiques
de évidemment de la caf identitaire de
l'îlotage la famille puis aussi le
sentiment d' imposteur qui peut y avoir
avec le fait d'être à moitié tibétaine à
moitié québécoise donc ne plus
appartenir à aucune cause d'un peu
solide et du texte de base
super à la lecture publique que j'avais
faite et m'a fait lire son texte il
avant d'ajouter automatiquement touchés
par cette expertise je suis reconnu dans
tout ce qu'elle a écrit donc je pense
qu'à ce moment là les dons ne sautez sur
l'occasion en fait de prendre ce texto
pour en faire une création comme on est
les deux comédiens qu'on travaille dans
le domaine du genre tu qu'on avait aussi
le désir de travailler ensemble et
éventuellement dans le futur aussi dit
que c'est vraiment le moment de plonger
dans la craie en citant la création
ensemble donc de là est née notre
premier spectacle nos premières
créations bat à la paix après deux trois
ans de travail de dur labeur de
collaboration aussi avec concepteurs
donc unis notre notre petit délit bâtard
donc tout ça c'est vraiment la question
sous vide ou qui auraient été
l'étincelle qui a fait
c'est déclencher tout le projet piste
une question qui nous a portés qui nous
a nourris tout au long de la création
laisse pas deviner une autopsie drôle
quand papa match comme pas avec la face
et au québec depuis qu'un site web est
vraiment belle brune alors pourquoi
fallait-il raconté s'est fort bien pour
nous au départ cette création là c'est
vraiment un autre saisisse d'une quête
identitaire qui était vraiment à la base
personnelle dont une part personnelle
donc le fait d'avoir aussi commencé à
première de création mais nos propres
expériences le fait travailler en
famille ensemble d'aller chercher dans
nos vidéos darchy d'enfance
c'est vraiment une démarche genre
d'exploration pu aussi un désir de
réellement comprendre d'où elles sont
vives puis c'est devenu vraiment comme
une mission au terme de deux mois
vraiment puis rapidement on s'est rendu
compte aussi que vingt sept ces
questions là qu'on se posait mais on
avait aussi envie de porter à 5 pour y
répondre nous mais aussi pour pour faire
en écho à ce que les personnes ou
d'origine mixte ou si les autres
personnes dont une mixte peuvent vivre
donc c'était aussi un envie de mettre ça
sur scène d'exposer ses réalités leur
fait partager au plus grand nombre afin
de tenter de comprendre un peu mieux ce
de rendre les gens sensibles à ces
questions le coup dit est ce que tu as
déjà rencontré le dalaï lama
j'ai commencé à faire de la méditation
vaincu tous et qui parlait ce beau sport
la boj chinois cartonnait madar est
filmé dans le documentaire sept ans au
tibet doit rapidement en fait on s'est
rendu compte dans notre processus puis
aussi quand leurs portes à la scène
qu'on l'a présentée devant un grand
public qui était la question de la quête
identitaire
en fait la recherche de stabilité
finalement c'est quelque chose qui est
assez universel
qui les gens qu'ils soient qui était
d'obliger le mix mais des fois même pas
nécessairement disaient qu'ils se
reconnaissaient aussi puisqu'ils étaient
touchés par ce qui il voyait aussi un
lien avec l'histoire de leur famille de
leurs parents de leurs grands parents
donc je pense que c'est ces besoins là
en fait de reconnecter avec 6,6 origines
qui de essayer de tenter de comprendre
ensemble collectivement et doit s
convient finalement puis des décennies
[Musique]